you know as as i'm as i'm going through
green lights especially with your father
what a complex guy i thought um
because it seems almost like violence in
some form
was a love language for him you tell
that story of your brother
having the right of passage when your
father had taken him to this
place and wanted him to steal something
and your brother didn't want to do it
and so your brother and he get into this
knock down dragon
and the moment your brother hits him
with a 2x4 and he's passed out and your
brother's like oh dad dad dad
and then when he comes two that's my boy
[Laughter]
crying weeping tears going that's my boy
thank you and they were best friends
from that day on
best friends my my dad never challenged
him morally philosophically
never talked to him as a as a younger
man a son or a subservient ever again in
his life
and the same thing happened to you same
thing happened to you in a rite of
passage
where you had stolen a pizza one night
not stolen the pizza but yeah
yeah you had an incident as a pizza you
said okay
you you you had an incident about a
pizza
came home and your father asked you
about the pizza
you lied about it and
tell us about that moment well
i tried to you know note to
to children out there when you've done
something wrong and you come home and
your parents go
so uh did you pay for that pizza if you
didn't pay for it it means they know you
didn't
okay so i tried to weasel out of it and
go well i mean i think
i mean would you do in this the more i
was groveling the more i was digging
myself a whole the more my father was
getting angry
and almost feeling like what have i done
wrong i'm giving you a chance son to
tell me you stole it
i think in his mind he's like i've stole
plenty of pizzas when i was a kid just
tell me and i didn't have the courage to
tell him as soon as i said
well no i mean i thought he gave me a
backhand and one that i had earned
and he sat through he was like what am i
supposed to do son what am i supposed to
do
just tell me be man enough to just tell
me and if i would have told him
hey daddy we had we got we stole a pizza
jesus didn't know he'd get caught he'd
been like gosh
damn it now somewhat i teach you
shouldn't do that and then damn if
you're going to do it
get away with it better but i got my
rite of passage later
in life with him yes that night at over
the bar
having punching out a guy in the moment
and who had put his hand on my dad yes
yeah and coming out of it your dad said
that's my boy and so many words he
basically pulled me off the guy and said
that's enough son
that's enough and then i remember him
calling his friends and you know
saying hey the youngest one is what he
called me the youngest one
matthew i was the mom as well he's going
to be okay he's going to be okay
he's got a bit of a berserker switch but
he's going to be okay and that was
you know for him yeah it was initiations
and right to passage and you know he
grew up a different generation he was a
physical man as you've read in this
story in the book
those hands that could hurt were also
those hands that healed
from from birds to my mother to to to
his children
you know well you just mentioned being
the muhammad's mama's boy a
self-proclaimed mama's boy you write
about spending most of your time with
your mother
growing up because your dad was often on
the road
and how do you think that shaped you
um well mom and i were good buddies i
mean she was my kindergarten teacher she
was a seventh grade teacher she was my
substitute teacher along the way we
would ride to school together on a bike
and
we'd we'd mimic that froot loop
commercial with toucan sam right behind
you baby
right behind you baby and dad wasn't
gone for
long periods of time he would just be on
the road traveling through
texas peddling pipes selling pipe trying
to get accounts
he was not my little league coach or my
soccer coach or football coach like he
was maybe from my older brothers
but i understood i mean we had moved
there
longview was a fast growing place the
oil business was good he was busy
and so i spent a lot of time with with
mom
it wasn't like dad wasn't in my life i
just didn't have him in my daily life
like maybe my big brothers did
you